dark tide is a first person Co-op
shooter set in the grimdark universe of
Warhammer 40 000.
soldiers of the mobian sixth the
sprawling Hive city of tertion stands on
the brink of Destruction the only thing
standing between these chaos worshiping
Heretics and Victory
the mysterious Inquisitor Grendel and
his warband of conscripted convicts
you are one such reject
freeing to serve the emperor's light in
this darkest of ours
you can expect no help no reinforcements
you are turcian's last line of defense
your first task is to select your class
you four to choose from the choice you
make will determine your play style
veterans are seasoned soldiers of the
Astra militarum the famed Imperial Guard
and focus primarily on ranged weapons
like lasgens to secure the kill
fueled by holy Roth zealots prefer to
charge headlong Into The Fray they are
holy Warriors who stop at nothing to
purge heresy in the emperor's name
psychers draw on the unfathomable powers
of the war but like all great Powers
theirs comes with a price use their
abilities too often and they may need an
untimely again
watch the muscle-bound and simple-minded
ogreens lacking tactical understanding
they more than make up more with
prodigious strength than fortitude
once you've made your choice it's time
to bring your reject to Life by choosing
their appearance personality and
backstory
body type facial features hairstyles and
tattoos are all customizable every
character type also has three unique
voice profiles each with an extensive
range of lines that will showcase your
rejects personality as you play
Barber
your reject's contribution to the battle
pattern begins at the mission terminal
here you'll choose from an endless
stream of missions some more urgent and
perilous than others each playing a key
role in tertium survival
missions require strike teams of four
operatives if you're not in a Strike
Team you'll automatically be matched
with others from Grendel's warband when
you embark on a mission a mission's
difficulty can vary so Choose Wisely
from the available options dead heroes
serve no one
every Mission has a primary objective
which can be anything from retrieving
vital supplies to assassinating an arch
heretic Inquisitor Grendel's trusted
servants will update your strike team's
progress and goals as you fight your way
through the map offering guidance new
objectives and occasional Pros as the
situation merits good luck succeed or
fail the end of round will summarize
your performance and tally any rewards
to survive intersham players will need
to master both melee and ranged combat
switching seamlessly between the two as
the need arises
every encounter pits you against a
variety of enemies each with their own
fighting style it'll be up to you to
determine how best to Vanquish them
using the weapons at your disposal
when engaging hand to hand you'll use
blocking and shoving to keep your
enemies off balance then finish them off
with brutal close combat weapons such as
the faux shredding chainsawed or the
punishing Thunder hammer
fighting at range requires that you take
full advantage of available cover as you
return Fire With lazgans Grenades and
psychic bullets as the enemy closes
you'll employ strafing and dodging
staying one step ahead of the hordes to
make sure you're not overwhelmed
no reject can survive alone
teamwork is everything in dark tide work
with your Strike Team or die alone
your innate toughness your determination
to press on through the pain recharges
when you're near your Strike Team
if that's not enough to encourage you to
stay close to your friends wandering off
risks being punished by those looking to
immobilize or capture stray rejects such
as the slabbering chaos Hound or the
mobian trapper
once you've all prayed to such enemies
only your teammates can save you
gaining Inquisitor Grendel's favor is no
easy task but a necessary one if you're
to survive
serve diligently and you will learn new
Secrets earn greater responsibilities
and perhaps even become a trusted member
of the warband
as you progress through the game and
level up your character you'll choose
Feats to further customize your unique
play style you'll also earn the trust of
the warbands tech priest and access to
her Shrine of the omnisaya where you
will customize your weapons using
materials collected during your missions
you can upgrade the weapons Rarity or
refine its blessings and perks to create
the perfect tool for vanquishing
Heretics a reject lives or dies by their
War gear better it's the best it can be
the battle for tercium is only just
beginning
in the coming weeks and months dark
Tide's story will expand with seasonal
content bringing new objectives new maps
new dangers and new challenges to keep
you and the rest of Grendel's warband on
your toes tertium
the emperor calls you Grendel offers you
the purpose
it's time for the rejects to rise